nicht der anderen fußball noch nie
was das denn bitte
so leute das wasser ist leider schon
wieder mit dem video ich hoffe natürlich
es hat euch sowie mal gefallen und ja
wenn euch dieser kurzen halt so wirklich
gefallen hat dann würde es mich freuen
wenn ihr mich halt mal wieder mit dem
daumen nach oben unterstützt und das
video vielleicht mitteilt oder so wenn
sie nicht ganz so gefallen hat dann geht
natürlich auch noch nach oben was auch
ganz nett und ja ich bin ein bisschen
heiser meinen teil hab ich es aber
wieder vom shirt gekriegt und jetzt habe
ich gerade geduscht und ich bin ein
bisschen erkältet aber egal ob auf jeden
fall geht es hier unten rechts weiter
mit meinem video dort ging es um einen
forderten dagegen sein haus von unten
rechts mit meinem falle zu
dort ging es um dinge die ich hasse und
facebook instagram alles ohne in der
video beschreibung deckt das war und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten video nächste
woche drei leute